Nero don't fall asleep in front of Kim
jong-un he had his defense team executed
for the crime of nodding off at some
event possibly a performance of the
children's Orchestra
yeah so if you're in Kim's inner circle
just to be on the safe side you might
want to pick up a pair of these neuro
when Courtney Love is accused of not
paying her bills you can't report it as
news
Courtney psychiatrist says she owes him
48 grand and that's just for steam
cleaning the couch near all summer nest
explained to this Kentucky man who
accidentally shot his own mother during
a church wedding that when the minister
says forever hold your peace we've just
learned done Oh America new rule if
someone catches you having sex with the
tailpipe of a car
stop it sir when they said you needed an
emissions check they meant the car man I
thought I was getting screwed at the
pump new rule don't be like Lewis
Langley South Carolina Republican who
refused to buy Obamacare until he
started going blind and now he wants
Obamacare don't worry mr. Lang President
Obama is aware of your situation and he
has something for you